hello everyone and welcome back to the
1918 tournament of New York this is
Round four and we've already seen one
game well two games actually but the
game against Frank James Marshall I did
over a year ago so I do hope you enjoyed
that game if you haven't it will be
again the first link you will see in the
description below in the previous game
kappa blanka defeated morrison and the
game against Roy Turnbull black was
drawing round 2 so this is a como Blanca
goes into round 4 with two wins and one
draw now here he faces his old rival
Oscar highest I say rival as he lost the
games to s lost him to oscar highs in
the 1916 tournament also in new york but
the rice Memorial Tournament we covered
that game two games ago the two videos
ago prior to this one and we also have
this photo we checked it out in the
previous video all rights a couple banca
vs. highs but this is not from round 4
this actually from around 11 s
Capablanca has the black pieces here so
excellent opportunity for kappa blanka
to get his revenge for the excellent
loss he received in the 1916 rice Morel
tournament but s Capablanca said in that
game has just played a brilliant game
kappa blanka didn't continue in the best
way every possible time in the highest
discontinued in the best possible way
every time and that of course resulted
in Capablanca losing the game so let's
see how about--how Capablanca deals with
this opportunity to get his revenge
Komaki opens with E for and Oscar goes
for ee6 the fringe defense it's the
defense kappa blanka used against him in
the 1961 Morial tournament that he lost
the four we have d5 Knight to c3 Knight
to f6 Bishop to d3 now Capablanca
deviates from the line that was played
in the rice Memorial Tournament
d capture sunny for Knight captures on
e4 and now Knight B to d7 Capablanca
trades on f6 with Knight captures Knight
captures in now Knight to f3 and here
Bishop to e7 just continuing development
Queen to e2 by capablanca and highest
castles and Bishop to g5 of course with
h6 capablanca captures with Bishop
captures he gives up the bishop pair
Bishop captures and now comes Queen to
e4 and already you have this position
where you might think howcome Capablanca
gives up the disrepair so early in the
game but here you can see that he's
already threatening checkmate Queen to
h7 is the idea and black is already
forced to weaken his position either by
playing g6 or by going up to eight rook
to e8 is not well it's not a bad move
but it doesn't lock win to h7 but black
is in no real danger here the Queen the
King will be very safe on e7 but somehow
in a real game you don't want to do this
even though here white King is also
vulnerable you can just continue with c5
and well black black should be even
better in this position but highest goes
for g6 it's the natural move but you
have created a weakness and capablanca
waits no longer he just continues the
attack with h4 the idea is h5 hunt of
course black will not be able to capture
because the idea is the same just going
to h7 checkmate and here blacks best
course of action would be Queen to d5
just offering a queen trade and you know
continuing to play the game but here our
highest bows g5 he says my king is
safely castle yours isn't let's open up
the center and kappa blanka calculates
properly he plays d captures on e5 with
Bishop to f5 now the line for this
bishop is open with Queen to f4 and
Bishop captures on b3 and of course you
don't want to capture C captures D as
well we don't want to mess up your pawn
structure and you prefer to keep your
lines of attack open so here a couple
Blanca castles Queen side and now the
bishop cannot move as black would lose
the Queen so here it's only a temporary
piece sacrifice rush up to g7 getting
the bishop out of harm's way
rook captures on d3 also a nice root
lift without losing time this the other
look is coming to d1 as well so the
rooks will be nicely doubled on the D
file Queen to e7
and now just Queen to C for keeping
around is diagonal h5 will be a very
nice threat and also as you'll see later
the Queen for NC 4 covers the b v square
which will be important later with rook
a to d8 Capablanca no doubles and the D
file we have rook H to d1 and now comes
Roe captures on d3 rook captures on d3
and now rook to e8 here with a triple
attack against the e5 pawn but there is
no immediate danger of losing the pawn
so first couple Annika just goes c3
giving his King some extra breathing
space also taking away the be four
square from the black key a queen in the
future and here
you still can't capture if you capture
here then it's just night capture screen
captures and rook III and now you can
see that it was very important that the
b v square is covered from the black
queen if Queen be five then the Queen
would be able to guard the rug here you
would just have to give up queen for a
rook as there is no good square if you
just move the Queen and rook captures
rook so after this c3 move we have c6 by
black and now just rook to e3 capablanca
increases the defense now of d5 pawn so
there is no immediate threat of
capturing it and with with the c6 move
black also covers the b v square
so his King would have a retreat after
the the given line but the rook would
also have to move but okay c5 here as
now the rook moved from the D file
there's no more pressure of winning d5
pawn and now comes King to C do here
capablanca will play g4 and he will
transfer his King all the way to the to
the King side with b6 by black
strengthening the this c5 pawn with a4
and the now comes Queen to d7 we have
looked to d3 now forcing the Queen to
move back we need to c8 and now comes
Queen to e4 and the Queen just moves
back we have Queen to e6
now comes Luke to d5 again with a triple
defense of the e5 pawn and King to f8
you can see that black doesn't really
have a a better option
the the Queen side is pretty much closed
you don't really have any good playing
on the Queen side as black nor do you
want to move your pawns on the King side
as black and there's really not much to
do in the center so black will just have
to wait and see what Capablanca does we
have King to f8 now comes c4 just
strengthening cementing that broken d5
also preventing any a 6 B 5 action with
King to g8 is just repeating and b3 now
we have King back to f8 and the now
capablanca transfers his King over to
the
Kings side with King to d3 now comes
King to g8 and rook the d6 pushing the
Queen back we have Queen to c8 and now
kappa blanka repeats rook to d5 singing
if black will repeat with queen t6 if
black repeats Quinte says then
Capablanca will look for a different
plan heist
does repeat and only now that capablanca
expand on the Kings side with g4 King to
f8 and the now comes Queen to f4 we have
King to g8 by black and out comes Quinta
efore just repeating came to f8 and not
come skiing to e2
sorry about that if you're wondering
about the funny hat my niece made it for
me she asked if I would like a hat made
for me and I said sure III you know I
like a hat if it will be a pirate hat
and she actually made a pirate hat as
you can see there's the the little
pirate skull over there so it's a pirate
hat but it's it doesn't fit my head so I
was gonna plan a plan to wear it for the
entire video but it simply doesn't work
so sorry about that but okay highest
repeats we have King to g8 and now King
to f1 Capablanca wants to get his king
over to g3 push h5 and gets his king
even further up the board with King back
to f8 highest just repeats as capablanca
blocked the entire position we have King
to g2 and now king back to g8 we have
King to g3 King to f8 black just repeats
and now comes finally h5g captures on
h5g chapters on h5 and now Queen to e7
and now comes Queen to f5 here
capablanca prepares a very deadly move
but black is without a plan so he just
continues moving the King King to g8 and
you can see for the past I believe six
or seven moves the black just went King
f8 King G king a 15 g8 and just you know
he's forced to wait and see what
Capablanca will do so feel free to pause
the video here and try to figure out
what was Capablanca the idea with this
whole King March and bringing
well all of his pieces to where they are
I'll give you a couple of seconds if you
want to figure out what kappa blanka
played for those of you who were able to
do it you are an excellent player and
for those of you who just wanna enjoy
show here kappa blanka went rook to d7
and now you can see that it's okay to
give up the five pawn but you're not
really giving up the e5 point and you do
have to capture it if you just move the
Queen then just real captures on a seven
you lose a valuable base of the pawn
chain then b6 is going then c5 is gonna
fall and what it's just gonna win by
pushing the Queen side pawn so that's
not acceptable for black here black
tried Bishop captures on e5 but now
comes the point of course you don't want
to capture if you capture you're just
going to you go into a better end game
after captures captures captures and
captures here but black can capture on
h5 and then now it's equal material but
white of course of course will have a
better game endgame but capablanca had
an even better idea
he just played King to g4 and now you do
have to play something with a queen if
you move the Queen let's say to a fake
then you lose the knight just brush-up
captures in you're down a piece so not
an option
highest wind Queen to f6 defending the
bishop but now comes the real problem
Knight captures on e5 and here you don't
really have a good response here if you
who capture the night let's say you go
Queen captures on e5 just Queen captures
on f7 check King moves and queen to h7
will be checkmate
so this is not possible on the other
hand if rook captures only five the
Queen is no longer guarded the bishop on
e5 was protecting the Queen so just
Queen captures Queen you're down a queen
you're gonna get to checkmate it very
soon in the game Queen g7 check happened
but here couple one who just played King
King to f4 and it was in this position
that Oscar hives resigned the game as
there is nothing to do here he's down
down a knight and well without any hopes
of saving the position I mean you kind
of have to play rook to f8 there's the
threat of just rook captures and f7 f7
square is attacked three times and after
we defense Capablanca we'll just keep on
cleaning up the Queen side now being up
a piece and this is of course completely
winning for white sir after King to a4
highest resigned the game and it was a
well it's fair to say it was a pretty
clean revenge for Capablanca for for his
loss to Oscar highs in the 1916 rising
Memorial Tournament
it was I mean
Heights resigned and move 45 and it was
a ever since move 25 Capablanca played
rook to d5 that highest went King to f8
and he just kept repeating pretty much
for 15 most kingi 1815 g18 a fake
Capablanca just you know created
everything and then the position just
played itself so an excellent game by
capablanca and really a worthy revenge
on his on his part so this is run for
Aqaba Monica is now three wins and one
raw and you know the the tournament is
only gonna keep getting better so if you
haven't seen it do check out capablanca
versus Marshall from round one I did do
that video a year ago I know my videos
were only at 30 frames per second back
then but you know we still have to watch
them so do check it out it will be the
first link in the description below if
you haven't seen it and if you haven't
seen kappa blanka vs. Oscar highs in the
1916 Rice Memorial Tournament do check
her out it will be the second link in
the description below
so yeah you know do do check it out but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Roman
Roman finta Francois Yann they've
galleon dummy put pirates and
Christopher brown for a conversion to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual even checked all
my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the 1918 tournament of New
York featuring Capablanca checking up on
your suggestions and you know just
seeing if anything important happens in
in the chess world for the end of this
video to check out the the pirate hat
once again there you have it just a very
nice pirate hat and yeah
thank y'all for watching I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day